randy gallows merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors donald trump
on vient de le voir qui invite les
américains à manifester contre un
confinement trop strict dans trois états
est ce bien raisonnable selon vous quand
on observe que le foyer le plus
important est bien dosé aux états unis
bonjour monsieur merci de m'avoir si
aujourd'hui je france c'est aussi une
question des libertés d'expression et le
droit de manifester aux états unis qui
est limitée qui est bien entendu
aujourd'hui on a une difficulté à
exprimer une voix d un certain nombre de
personnes dans certains états qui
s'estiment lésés par cette situation qui
n'ont plus rien pour vivre et qui
veulent aller au travail et peut-être il
ya des mesures qui peuvent être revus
par certains gouverneurs et qui est le
peuple à faire entendre sa position dans
ces quatre là alors le team voile le
dirigeant du minnesota a rétorqué que la
première responsabilité était de
protéger la population
si je pensais que nous pouvions
retourner travailler dès demain c'est
exactement ce que nous ferions at il
ajouté alors pourquoi finalement
émettent des doutes sur le choix d'un
confinement strict de la part de
certains gouverneurs selon vous je pense
aussi
on est en de maintes fois ci et les
dissensions qui existaient et comme
entendre les peurs sans qu il ya des
manifestations permet de les faire on
est aujourd'hui confronté à une
situation où chaque gouvernement
présente sa position sont que le peuple
soit entendu sur leurs positions l'eau
possibilité de gagner leur vie et à
leurs factures
c'est très très difficile pour beaucoup
d'américains pour faire face à leurs
vies tous les jours et il faut les
entendre et je crois c'est important
qu'ils puissent aller d'heure et dia le
gouverneur attention on a besoin de voir
les choses autrement
tnt n'est content et notre position et
vous voyez il n'y a pas de violence
plus tôt les médias aux états unis et
c'est du dior qui ça va générer la
violence aujourd'hui mais c'est des
pacifistes dans la rue et ils sont en
train de dia écouter nos idées dans
certains états il essaie d'utiliser ce
moment là pour passer d'autres
régulaient
pour limiter la réglementation sur les
armes alors que ça n'a rien à voir avec
les compliments et les colonnes viol
alors minnesota michigan virginie le
président américain appelle à libérer
trois états notamment gouverné par des
démocrates
cet appel du président finalement
beaucoup il voit une stratégie politique
plutôt qu'une stratégie sanitaire en vue
des prochaines élections qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
moi je pense que la question aussi ce
qu'on peut voir dans certains de ces
états qu'il ya aussi peut-être
désobstruction dont ces états qui ont
été assez important et qu'il y avait
aussi un suscité le président a bien
souligné ses devoirs est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres mesures peut-être mon
restrictives qui permettent aux
américains des pouvoirs les au travail
et peut-être des actions c'est la
liberté pour se rassembler et continuer
à vivre un petit peu plus normale dans
ce cas ce qu'on va aussi aujourd'hui
parlons des questions politiques
on voit dans le cas du conte démocrates
qu'ils essaient de passer des lois pour
permettre à les lois relatives aux
élections aux états unis sans pouvoir
identifier des électeurs il essaie de
passer des lois pour les votes à porte
ont dans ce sens qu on puisse identifier
si et les citoyens qui voter si c'est
bien cette personne
aujourd'hui on est à confronter un
situation qui est très grave aujourd'hui
au niveau politique qui le parti
démocrate de son côté essaie dé profiter
de la situation pour passer des lois qui
peut causer des fraudes aux élections
alors mais au moins il ya des
professionnels de santé aussi qui qui
s'inquiètent en inde et confinement
précipité avec ce risque d'une deuxième
vague
le pays est-il préparer justement à une
éventuelle deuxième vague
je pense moi je suis pas en position de
députés à six après hop après moi
j'estime quai il faut faire ça par
étapes comme beaucoup d'états et
beaucoup aidé en train de les faire
après a considéré que si aujourd'hui
votre discussion
si les peuples ont le droit d'exprimer
leur mécontentement
dalé et diarra leurs gouverneurs alors
gouvernement qui est attention les
situation est très difficile pour nous
on a besoin
que les choses soient revues essayer
d'être moins respect moins restrictif
par pour nos libertés permettait de nous
d'aller travailler dans des conditions
moins dures telles que la réglementation
a été mis en place
c'est tout ce qu'ils demandaient si vous
avez écouté bien c'est pas dire on vous
dit confiné à son profond rives viser là
les compliments le raye essaie de nous
permettre d'aller au travail un petit
peu pour voir si on peut vivre mieux par
rapport à ce qu'ont été mis en place par
rapport à la réalité sanitaire existe
sur le champ pour conclure plus
généralement comment l'action du
gouvernement trump en tout cas quel
retour vous avez sur cette action
comment est ce qu'elle est perçue par
les américains comme dans situation la
plupart des américains sont derrière
leur président je pense qu' il sut 15
son peuple et se rend compte que rester
plus longtemps confiné va voir inas avec
des conséquences dramatiques pour le
pays
ce qu'on se rend pas compte c'est quand
on venait d'avoir à la répulsion den
guerre économique d'origine biologique
qui vient de la chine qui a profité par
sa vague des désinformations com est à
plat l'économie américaine et les pulls
économie du monde et maintenant tous ces
pays doit faire face à cette situation
aujourd'hui
mais notre président essaie d prévoir et
essayer de savoir comment il peut faire
pour remonter la pente et voir comment
sauver notre économie et il vous verrez
que dans les mois à venir les peuples
bande en connaissance des situations et
ils vont trouver la force et les courage
pour faire face à cette situation
merci randy yalouz d'avoir répondu à nos
questions j'appelle que vous êtes avocat
et président des républicains overseas
merci à vous